2, 1, swap!
Wait,
we have to sing the better one.
We have to sing the better one.
I always wanted a brother.
Just like you.
What did you say about my brother?
That's how straight up my brother.
For those who don't know what skin I'm on.
I don't know, what was the thing that changes your POV?
F5.
F5?
I'm not allowed.
I always wanted a brother.
It's not as straight as my brother.
It's my brother.
Just like you.
So guys, today we're here to explore.
Look at this.
We're going to become Disney.
Explore world's adventures.
We know where we wanna go.
Oh yeah.
We were originally gonna do the Disney world one.
And then I was looking up Minecraft DLC.
I saw this.
So we switched.
I was like, oh my god.
But what do you mean adventure mode?
Wait, there's quests?
Yeah, there's quests to unlock more worlds.
So I guess we go sandbox.
We can go straight to Simba.
But we do adventure with the explore all the worlds.
I was gonna say, I don't wanna.
I mean, we can try one maybe.
But I don't wanna like...
If it's bad, we'll just go straight to the one we really wanna go to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can do that.
Yeah, so...
I always have to go to...
Guys, if you're wondering why I have to tap the dressing room.
For some reason for me.
If I tap out, it kicks me out of the lobby.
So, this is my solution to that.
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know if everything is okay for us.
For me and Mint.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, everybody.
But yes, if we finish this, we'll go to Disney World.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like our reward.
Oh, did you buy that one?
No, I didn't.
Me neither.
But I feel like we should both buy it just for the skin pack.
Unless you wanna be a furry to Disney World.
Alright, here we go.
I'm pressing the button.
I'm pressing it.
Woah.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Where are we?
Wait, we're in Alice in Wonderland.
Is this Alice?
No.
Wait, no.
Where are we?
I don't know.
I'm gonna jump.
Oh my god, she's swimming, Naya.
Naya!
You can't contain me.
Can you feel the love tonight?
What the hell did I just grab?
Oh, how odd.
A visitor.
Seems you found this little refugee.
It's been a while since anyone else has shown up.
It's quite exciting.
I'm sure you feel the same.
But anyway, you must be wondering about all this.
Lucky for you, you're speaking to me.
While I lack an awakeness, I make up for it with knowledge.
To fill you in, this is the Dream Pavilion and it can lead you to all sorts of magical places.
You may or may not have seen before.
I hear they sometimes appear in our most treasured dreams.
The Dream Pavilion is a place of connection and records.
From here, you can always see what's happening.
You just need to know where to look.
However, if there's anything you need to know, don't hesitate to ask.
Oh my god, where am I?
Movie bar in.
What is that?
Wait.
Wait, I didn't want to use this.
What's going on?
There's a library here.
What's happening?
The record book of dreams.
It will automatically journal all sorts of information.
Just flip through.
In addition to the pavilion and the side rooms, this realm has some places to explore as well.
You can find some goodies around, I think.
Not that.
There's gems.
Gem shards.
Collecting them will store them here.
They will grant certain powers.
What is happening?
Oh, okay.
We have a compass.
This is the gem wand.
It'll get you back here.
This is so elaborate.
But it needs to be powered up first with a handy map.
And this is the crystal compass.
It's a peculiar device with many different powers.
But it runs on gem shards, so you'll need to collect some first before you can use any of them.
That should be it.
Do take care of it, but I'm sure you can handle it.
You forgot the yawn.
Okay, I got the quest.
I have a gem wand.
I already have a key.
There's mini games.
I'm gonna unlock something.
The wand, like, transports us to places.
Yeah, it said, like, do you want to return to the hub?
Okay, we got Aerial World.
Oh my god, look at our map.
Snow White.
We got Alice in Wonderland.
Aladdin.
Activate to detect...
What the fuck?
I can cross wide gaps to get temporary speed boost.
Now push heavy boxes.
Oh, we are too stupid for this.
Where do you think?
Who are you?
You too.
Who is that?
Is that some kind of ostrich?
Zazu keeps going on about Nala and I being betrothed.
I can't marry her.
She's my best friend.
Wait,
it better not be the water hole again.
No, it's not.
Uncle Scar told me about it.
Like, he told you about the elephant graveyard and we almost got eaten by hyenas?
That is different.
No one said it's forbidden.
Oh, he's a bad boy.
Maybe we should ask Zazu.
Fine, let's go to Pride Rock.
You coming, new friend?
Oh my god, look.
It's right over here.
Oh my god, there's Pride Rock!
It looks a lot smaller than I imagined.
Where's the rest of the animals?
Oh yeah, it's just because they ate them all.
It's like extinction here.
Isn't that the forbidden graveyard over there?
I think so.
We gotta get the gems too.
Oh my god!
Oh wait, three gems nearby before they disappear.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Before they disappear again?
Oh my god, it's time?
I think so.
I see them, I see them.
Where, where?
It's a blue gem.
I think.
Can I hit you?
I thought I turned PvP on.
You turned PvP on!
I tried!
Oh my, Disney won't let us commit violence.
Yeah, we tried to turn PvP on, you guys.
I tried to turn PvP on.
Oh my god, it's Abras!
Eat it, eat it!
There's only like four of each animal.
They've really done numbered.
It's Noah's Ark!
They've done numbers.
The lions are too hungry.
I'm so hungry.
Wait, what's this?
Oh my gosh, it's an elephant!
Oh my god, wait, is there also only four elephants?
They're so tiny.
They're really small.
I think so.
They're really tiny elephants.
Wait, there's Scar!
Wait, where?
Oh my god, my hero!
Wait, oh my god!
There he is!
What is he saying?
Read it.
I'm reading.
I wonder when my brother will next descend from on high to mingle with the commoners.
Oh, that's it?
That's all he's got to say?
That's where the comedy is?
How dare you?
My dad said I'll be king next.
Everybody look left.
Everybody look right.
Everybody look up.
Standing in the spotlight.
Not yet.
Yeah, I am a Nepo baby.
Oh my god, this elephant's climbing a tree.
I should turn down my music.
Yeah, how's the audio, everybody?
Actual, like, original music, too, for this game.
I know!
That's crazy.
It's looking Minecraft.
It's like Minecraft version of...
What the hell is this?
Oh, it's a wildebeest.
That's gonna kill my dad.
Oh my god, yeah.
That's the dad killer.
That's gonna kill my dad.
This is where I'm almost dying.
It looks like it needs to eat.
It's so skinny.
It's so starving.
How hungry are you?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Timon and Pumbaa gotta be in there.
Oh, Timon and Pumbaa's here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I gotta change my clothes real quick.
Oh, me too.
Alright, we're changing, everybody.
We're changing.
Yes.
Where are you?
I'm changing.
You're changing?
Oh, don't look, guys.
Don't look.
She's changing right now.
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
I'm in front of you.
Do you not see me?
Oh, I'm bloated.
Wait, let me...
Where are you?
Do you see it?
Turn around, turn around.
I don't see it.
Do you not see me?
I'm in front of you.
Where are you?
Hakuna Matata.
What a wonderful friend.
Where are you?
Oh my gosh, the wildebeest is really freaking out behind me.
I'm right beside you.
Where are you?
Wait, do you actually...
Wait, let me change.
I'll change my skin.
I'll be sass for a little bit.
So, do you see me?
Oh, yeah, yeah, I see you.
Do you see sass?
Okay, okay, do you see me now?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hakuna Matata.
What a wonderful friend.
I wonder how big these worlds are.
Wait, wait, wait.
Look at me.
Look at me real quick.
Oh, are you gonna dab or something?
I'm gonna...
Wait, what's... Oh, wait, here we go.
It's Hakuna Matata!
Let's go.
We should've been doing quests, but we're just out here.
We're just out here exploring.
Wait, there's a pathway over here.
Oh, we might be able to find an actual Timon and Pumbaa.
Yeah.
And then we'll kill them and take their...
Yeah, what?
We'll take their rolls.
We're skinwalkers.
Oh, I see them!
You see them?
Oh, my God.
Wait, he's so tiny.
Oh, my God, he's so small.
He's so tiny.
Oh, he's freaking out.
He's like, what the fuck?
Oh, do you remember the old Lion King CD-ROM games?
Did you play them?
No, I didn't.
Oh, my God.
I think that it has to be.
Hey, Timon, come here.
I found...
You know, you think it's a really juicy book grub?
Pumbaa, are you nuts?
That's obviously a big two-legged aardvark.
Oh, they're talking about us.
Look how small he is.
An aardvark?
Yeah, everyone knows aardvarks only eat bugs, so they're not dangerous.
Here, wait.
You voice Pumbaa, I'll voice Timon.
Okay, okay.
All right, come on.
Let's approach.
Slowly.
Okay, I'll be quiet.
I'm not burping.
You have to!
You can't burp on command!
Sorry.
Sigh.
And they've spotted us.
Oh, my God.
He's got attitude.
Wow, they look really brave and strong.
Oh, Timon, you don't think?
I guess he does.
What does that mean?
If this is really the protector we were hoping for, we can't be too obvious.
First, we make friends.
With games?
Exactly.
Say, brave warrior, might you be up for some friendly competition?
Yeah, wanna catch some grub?
Are we in?
Should we do it?
Yeah, let's get in.
I'm gonna look at instructions first.
I looked at the instructions.
Whoa, there's a cutscene.
Sorry.
Wait, did you go in?
Yeah.
Oh.
Operator's gonna search the part of the jungle to catch as many grub as they can.
But grubs can be tricky.
They may hide under these logs, so you'll need to rustle them out.
Don't forget...
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's a competition.
Wait, are you fighting?
Wait, I see you!
That's not me!
I'm not even...
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm inside you.
There's so...
Oh, my God.
Where are you?
There's so many taboos!
What is this?
Where are the bugs?
How do I pick them up?
Oh, I can't leave.
Wait, I don't...
Oh, my God.
You just ate them!
No, no, no!
That's mine!
How do you pick them up?
I didn't read!
You bitch!
The instructions didn't say how to pick them up!
I don't know.
Oh, you just run into it.
They're just eating.
I think.
Oh, wait.
No, you don't.
I don't know.
I don't know!
I got it!
We got five points!
We did it!
I think we're the worst version of Timon and Fumba.
How do we...
They had like five Timons, though.
Like, what the hell?
Why are there five?
Okay, let's read the instructions.
Okay, okay, okay.
Instructions.
Here are the rules.
You just click on the...
Like, the hitbox is so fun.
I tried clicking!
Me too!
They just run up and get them.
This is messed up.
Yeah, this is not fair.
There's like five.
Why are there five Timons?
I don't know.
Okay, okay.
They're multiplying.
Also, didn't they want our help?
Why are they beating us?
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
Okay, I'm trying my best.
How did we get five points before?
I don't know, actually.
I don't know how we got five points there.
How did we grab it?
I grabbed them one time!
It's not letting me!
Oh, it's right click!
It's right click!
It's right click.
Oh my god, I was...
Oh my god.
I got it, I got it.
Oh my god, I got him, I got him.
Wait, there was a guy here.
Oh, I got him.
Yeah.
I like the actual Minecraft music that's happening now.
We can do this!
We can beat them!
Where are they?
We're better, we're better.
The moment we beat them, we become Timon and Pumbaa.
Yeah, yeah, we're gonna...
Oh, okay.
No, no, no, we almost got it.
We figured it out.
We did it, we did it!
We got 40, I mean, we got 50 points.
We got 50, we did it!
That's right, we're Timon and Pumbaa now.
Yeah!
We're taking your skin now.
I did try right click earlier.
I don't know, probably the hitbox.
Yeah, probably the hitbox.
It's okay, we won.
We won.
Oh no, no more, please.
You guys can go die now, so we'll be the new Timon and Pumbaa.
We're better.
We stand on two legs.
Wait, what did they want us to do?
They didn't say congratulations or anything.
Oh, no, they did.
They said it to me.
Oh.
What the hell?
Also, my music died.
It was playing Minecraft music for a little bit, and then it just died.
Wait, I have other emotes?
Oh my god, what are emotes?
Oh my god, I want...
Wait, no, I have to pay for this, nevermind.
Yeah.
Wait, did you pay for your...
Did you pay for your dancing emotes?
I don't think so.
I don't know how I have this.
Wait, how do you have...
I just have a wave.
What's this?
You guys can see it in the top left corner.
I have...
I like the kick part.
It's so good.
Wait, hold on.
I want to see if you do it again.
Wait, no, not that.
Why do I have just regular Minecraft music playing?
Again!
It looks like the Megan dance.
Oh my god, look at him go!
This is not fair, all I could do is clap.
This is not fair.
This has like a skill issue.
It's not fair.
I can't either pay for it or...
The clouds.
Just notice them.
Wait, there's transformers emotes?
Wait, what the fuck is the transformer emote?
What do you mean by that?
There's like...
How do you find them?
Wait, okay, wait, I'm gonna find them.
Wait, where?
I want to see!
Wait, I'll find them and then I'll show you.
Oh my gosh, I'm back to normal.
Okay, okay, okay, wait.
How do I...
How do I clip this?
Clip...
No, you gotta...
There's a whole transformer still, see?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Watch this.
Watch this, okay.
Okay, okay.
He's like, I need to see this too.
Okay, watch this.
It was worth it.
Roll up, transformers.
More than meets the eye.
Wait, look, did you see the lady?
Yeah!
Where do you get the emotes?
Wait, I'm gonna just search.
Transformers.
You know when you press to change emotes...
and you scroll down, there's a transformer icon.
Wait, I don't even remember how I changed it.
There's a...
Oh my God!
There's a Tetris one.
There's Mega Man?
Oh my God.
Oh, I see, I see.
You see the transformer icon?
Optimus kick.
Wait, you're...
Yeah, mine's the...
For Devotee, you can still see his tail.
What the hell is this?
Oh my God!
Wait, there's an angry bird?
Angry bird!
There's Halo.
Anger management, this is so lame.
Wait, there's Spongebob.
Wait, there is?
Oh my God, there's Halo too.
Yeah.
Oh, there's Disney, what's this one?
Oh, superhero.
Wait, there's...
Oh my God, wait!
Wait, I just have enough!
I just have enough for this!
Okay, okay, okay.
What's happening here?
Oh my God!
Okay, okay, watch this.
Are you looking?
Hold on, hold on.
I'm looking at my own emotes.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, okay.
Do it, do it, do it.
Okay, are you looking?
Yeah, yeah.
No!
Oh wait, you're Sonic ready!
Gotta go fast!
Gotta go faster, faster, faster!
Does it actually make you run faster?
Try it.
No, I can't.
I can't move while emoting.
So you just run in place!
Hold on, I'm gonna buy one too.
Wait, not that.
Okay.
Guys, which one should I get?
There's so many.
There's so many!
What the hell is this?
Obama the Hedgehog.
Oh my God.
How does this one work?
Oh my God, oh my God!
I like how we're spending money in Minecraft.
I got these points for free, okay?
I'm sure you did.
Wait, there's an actual anime run.
Let's just...
There's actual Naruto.
Oh my God.
They have...
They have Ben 10.
That's how she created it.
There's so many.
Why the fuck do we play Java?
Right!
There's Batman.
We could've had this.
Oh my God, there is anime.
Okay, but I prefer Sonic 1 more.
I don't understand.
What's the squirrel one?
The squirrel one?
Is that from Playing Dead?
What the fuck kind of show is this?
I don't know.
Wait, there's more pages?
Oh my God.
No, the second page is just a little bit.
Oh, there's How to Train Your Dragon here.
What does Ben 10 do?
Going hero.
Oh, it's Ice Age!
The squirrel is Ice Age.
Posing like a hero.
What is this?
Dancing like...
Hakuna Matata.
Oh, there's Hakuna Matata here.
There's just a T-pose.
Wait, why are there two different types of T-poses?
And one is more expensive than the other one.
Wait, what?
I think there's like common versions and then there's rare versions.
But this is literally the same thing.
Yeah, it's the same emote.
What's the difference?
I like the Tetris one.
There is a dab one.
Oh, there's Tetris one.
Oh my God.
There's a drop one?
Yeah!
What is going on here?
Tetris dance?
That's a good one.
I sort of want to buy this, but it's spent five dollars.
I sort of want to be Tetris.
This is so good.
Oh my God.
There's like some really random ones.
Oh, I see the dab.
I see the dab.
Oh my God, I can make Puma do a dab.
It's his legacy.
Wait, bouncy ball.
Oh my God.
Yeah, he turns into a ball.
I saw that, yeah.
There's one rare.
Wait, maybe there's the ones that we want, but cheaper.
Like, try and find ones that you want, but as a common.
You know the gray ones?
I don't think I can find the Tetris one that's cheaper.
That's true.
The Tetris one is kind of insane.
Why doesn't Java... I know Java, you can have a mod where you can add emotes and stuff.
But like, this is just better.
I think maybe free emotes would be better than this.
But like, can I be a transformer?
What the hell is this?
Okay.
Autobots, roll out.
Oh my God, it's dark.
Wait, what emote did you buy?
I didn't buy one.
Wait, I thought you were going to buy one with your free coins.
Okay, I'll buy one with my free coin.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, do it.
Oh, somebody, thank you Cas for the super chat for Tetris.
Thank you, it's worth it.
Wow.
Okay, guys.
That's the only thing I want.
The Tetris one was the only one I want.
Okay, let me buy this.
Don't worry, it's worth it.
Alright, I bought it.
I tabbed out to buy Tetris.
Okay, give me a sec, I'm buying my Tetris emote.
No, no, watch me.
Thank you guys for enabling me.
I really appreciate it.
I'm purchasing in progress.
Thanks for the super chat.
Thank you everybody.
Let's do it together, are you ready?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
3, 2, 1, go.
Go.
One more time, one more time.
3, 2, 1, go.
Oh.
Okay, we should progress the world.
Yeah, let's go do the world things now.
Wait, are we doing the quest or do we just want to explore?
I think we could talk to them because they might have stuff for us.
Oh, Simba and Nala?
We'll be like, sorry, we're too busy Tetrising.
We're definitely Timon and Pumbaa.
Yeah, we're your friends.
Wait, I'm collecting the gems.
What a wonderful phrase.
Do you think we can go to the little crevice that Simba died at?
Yeah, where Simba's dad died?
I think it's here.
I think so too.
I think it's literally here.
Oh my god!
Wait, we can recreate it!
Oh my god, we can recreate it!
Simba...
Wait, there's something over there, do you see it?
Oh my gosh, that's probably his soul.
Oh my god, is that dad?
You're not him anymore.
The gorge.
Oh, what's this?
You collected one collectible of this world.
Oh, is that my dad?
My dad's dead body?
Dad's dead body.
What is that?
What's that?
I can sense gem shards behind...
If only you could jump such a distance.
Oh, it's just to get gem shards.
Yeah, but those unlock things.
It's like my dad's soul, I collected him.
He's just a collectible.
Wait, what if I jump here?
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is where we have to be able to jump.
Wait, I see something else!
Magic wand.
Oh wait, I don't want to return to hub.
How do I...
What the hell is that?
Where are you?
Wait, is that another collectible?
That's what I thought, but it's actually a person.
Oh, it's the hyena!
Yeah, you gotta go up from here.
Alright, what does he say?
Oh, he was a collectible!
Oh my god, we collected the hyena!
He's ours now.
He's our pet now.
Oh shit, I was so close.
I got it.
Oh, parkour!
Okay, now I don't know what to do.
Jump again?
Okay, now I can't do the jump here.
I think we should...
I thought we were talking to Simba and Nala.
We're going, we're going.
Alright, alright.
Am I looking at the map?
Oh, it's on the other side.
Can you feel the love tonight, Timon?
I can see what's happening.
Some... I don't know.
Oh, there they are.
They fell in love and they're lying.
You can talk to him.
Alright, this is our home.
Pride Rock.
And I'm gonna be the king someday.
Let's hurry up and find Zazu.
Where could he be?
Zazu?
Where's Zazu?
Oh god, they're gone.
Oh, okay.
Oh, goodbye.
Okay, we have to find Zazu.
Oh, Zazu.
Like, I'm looking at the map.
Zazu should be like right here.
He's up here.
Wait, he's on Pride Rock?
Yeah.
Zazu, what are you doing up here?
That's for the monkey.
Oh my gosh, there's lions in here.
Wait, I wanna see.
Oh, it's Mufasa.
Look, I've never seen a creature like this around here.
Neither have I, Zazu.
But they don't look like trouble.
We're Timon and Pumba.
Hello, I'm Mufasa.
Welcome to- Wait, he's alive!
He hasn't died yet!
Are we gonna recreate their deaths?
Oh my god.
We're gonna recreate their deaths.
Let's go!
I must ask, did my son bring you here?
He has a knack for surprises.
Speaking of your son, sire, I'd better have a look at what he and Nala are up to.
I don't have a good feeling about it.
You never do, Zazu.
We can find Simba outside Pride Rock.
Oh hey, is that mom?
Oh, they don't wanna talk to us.
No, but they have a collectible!
Oh, there's Rafiki!
Rafiki is that thing.
Alright, where is...
It's like over there.
Oh, do we go to the Elephant Graveyard?
Oh, there they are!
Where?
I see them.
Right here.
Alright, my turn.
There you are, Zazu.
Can we go to the jungle, please?
The jungle?
Don't be ridiculous.
You have any idea how dangerous that would be?
It's outside the Pride Lands.
Where are more lions?
But Uncle Scar said there's nothing a lion would have to be afraid of there.
Yeah.
A grown lion, perhaps, but a cub?
I'm not so sure.
Come on, Zazu.
It'll be fun.
Besides, what could happen while you're with us?
I'm really not.
Hey, don't you dare run off!
Come back!
Sire, you're here!
Simba...
Mufasa just shows up, pops out, like...
Nala, where do you think you're going?
I told you leaving the Pride Lands would be dangerous.
What is he gonna say?
Everything the sun touches is ours.
And you try to drag Zazu along with you?
I'm sorry, Dad.
I just thought it'd be fun.
It's only the jungle.
Simba...
You're too...
You're too young.
And someday, you will be king.
That is a very big responsibility, requiring you to be responsible.
I know, Dad.
I'm really sorry.
Well, I'm glad I caught you before anyone was hurt.
Now we're going home.
Sorry, we can't show you the jungle.
I bet it's really cool.
We can't show them, but maybe they can tell us what it's like.
What do you... Oh my God, they talk so much.
It's already the sun's out already.
Think about it.
They're not forbidden from leaving the Pride Lands.
They can go there and tell us about it.
Oh yeah!
Then we'll see how fun it'll be when we get there.
Of course, that'll be a long time when we're grown.
Then it's a plan.
Will you go to the jungle on a scouting mission for us?
You will?
Awesome!
We already went to the jungle.
Let's do it again.
Let me show you something.
Come over here.
Okay.
Follow me.
Simba, follow me.
Oh, we gotta get the other three gems.
Collect two gems before they disappear again.
The baobab tree.
Oh, is this where Rafiki lives?
Oh my God, this is a tall-ass fucking tree.
Oh, there he is!
The weather is very particular, don't you think?
Peculiar.
Wait, he said something else.
What did he say?
I tried to...
Something else popped up.
Did you guys see it?
Okay, we talked to him.
No, it didn't show up again after.
Maybe I clicked on you.
No?
I know who you are, but it's... Oh, he knows who we are.
What?
He knows who we are.
Oh, he's dancing!
Watch out, Rafiki!
Watch out!
You're gonna get Tetris!
I just want to recreate Mufasa's death.
Maybe that's the end of the story.
If he dies.
We're just gonna see him die?
I thought he was gonna...
I thought someone was gonna grow up.
I mean, we have to go to the jungle.
Yeah, we gotta go to the jungle first.
Let's see if we can recreate his death first.
But usually they, like, disappear.
Let's go to the jungle and see if there's anything over there now.
Where did you go?
Towards the jungle.
Where are you?
I'm going to the jungle.
I'm following the pathway.
I see Scar.
I went the other way.
I was in front of Pride Rock.
Oh, okay.
So, I'm going...
I'm looking at my map.
I have a map.
You know, we all have that map now.
I don't need a map.
I wonder if we can change the timeline.
Save him?
We can save Mufasa?
Save Mufasa!
We just killed Scar right now.
Where are you?
I'm heading to the jungle.
I'm literally in the jungle.
So am I.
The mighty jungle.
The lion sleeps tonight.
I'm already here.
Me too!
No, you're not.
Yes, I am.
Somebody is a snow poke.
I'm in the jungle.
Yeah, I'm next to them.
I don't think we need to talk to them again.
Yes, we do.
It's literally on the map.
It is?
Wait, is it?
Oh wait, no, you're right.
Quest log.
What's the point of going here?
Wait, let's see.
I don't think there is anything else we need to do.
Ok, we have to find all the wild gems.
Yeah, these are collectibles.
Yeah, but then why the fuck did...
I'm eating my book right now.
Can you see?
Who needs a ring?
Ring is for losers.
Yeah, for nerds.
We ain't no nerds.
Do we just have to talk to them again?
Talk to Simba again?
Simba, hurry up.
We want to kill your dad.
What if we already did everything we need to do?
Except we have to find the collectibles and stuff.
There's no way Simba is supposed to grow up.
I'm pretty sure he's supposed to grow up.
We've explored the jungle.
No, we haven't actually.
We gotta find the hidden hyenas.
Oh my god, this is kind of crazy.
I'm talking to Simba.
Oh no, there's a stuck zebra.
There's a zebra.
I'm talking to them.
Let him die.
It's the circle of life.
Ok.
It also keeps going on about Nala and I being betrothed.
I can't marry her.
She's my best friend.
Yeah, I said that earlier.
Yeah.
Wait, what the fuck?
Is that not the jungle that we went through?
That has to be the jungle, right?
It is, but I think there's way more of the jungle.
I'm already...
I've explored all the jungle already.
Oh my god, all of it?
I hear the wild whispers of a dazzling leap.
I'm in the jungle.
Whispers of a leap?
What the hell are you talking about?
Do you think if we do the minigame again, it unlocks the jungle?
Oh, maybe.
Wait, hold on before you do.
How do I do this?
I'm in the jungle too.
Oh, I'm in the...
Wait, where's the famous water area for the jungle?
Oh, I found a famous tree!
What famous?
Are you in the famous Lion King tree?
There's no famous tree.
No, if you don't know, Hakuna Matata was...
Oh my god, you're in the gorge.
Do you need me to start the game so you can get out of there?
I don't know how to get out of here.
I don't know how to use the power-ups.
Use your wand!
Wait, really?
Wait, no, I think that takes you out.
Wait, if you left-click it though, you get other stuff.
Oh.
Wait, no you don't.
It teleports to the mini-game.
Wait, it's the jungle!
I teleported to the jungle!
Oh, I can do that too!
Yeah, use your magic wand!
Alright, let's catch some grub.
Alright, we got this.
We're so much better now.
Right-click, right-click.
Interact with them.
Alright, we're better than them.
Yeah, that's mine.
That's mine.
Oh, I got Minecraft music again.
No, no, no!
Bitch!
We're a team, what do you mean bitch?
I wasn't talking to you!
I was talking to actual Pumba!
I am actual Pumba, what do you mean?
I am him.
Oh no, he took...
Oh, there's a beetle.
That's right, we're faster than you.
I'm getting so many points.
Me too, we have 60...
Oh my god, we're 65, we're literally gonna starve to death.
We are sweeping, we are sweeping.
No, Pumba!
Three times a charm.
They're gonna starve.
We're gonna eliminate the entire bug population.
Yeah, they'll have nothing.
They'll have nothing.
Come on, let me get that one.
Slimy yet satisfying.
Oh my god, we're at 103!
Alright, we did it.
We've explored the jungle.
We got outgrubbed by the rookie.
That's right!
Get outgrubbed!
Yeah, this is what I have to say about that.
Transformers, roll out.
You become the size of Timon when you do that.
Final boss, roll out.
Well, that didn't do anything.
Wait, follow me though, follow me.
Oh, I'm following you?
Oh wait, do you wanna go talk to them?
And I'll try and get the other stuff in the jungle.
No, you just TP.
No, there's more back here.
There's more back here?
Yeah, why do you think I fell into the gorge?
But what does that mean?
It's not gonna progress the story.
I don't know, let me go talk to them.
Oh see, it's the famous bridge.
It's the Lion King bridge.
Oh, this is when they go...
No, it's Hakuna Matata.
Wait, you wanna see something really dramatic?
Yeah.
No!
Simba.
Remember who you are.
Wait, can I die in here?
I wonder.
I'm gonna try and drown myself.
You're gonna drown?
Let's see what happens.
Remember who you are.
Wait, before we die.
I'm dying and I'm...
I'm dying while I emote.
Wait, I'm healing at the same time though.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, I think we're on...
No, no, we can out-damage them.
I died!
Oh!
We're back at the jungle.
Oh, we're back in the jungle.
Hello.
Back home.
I don't wanna live here.
It's not my home.
I don't understand.
Why won't it let us get out?
Wait, there's more to the jungle.
That's weird.
Have you been listening to anything I've been saying?
And look, there's the famous Lion King bridge.
Oh, I'm a fucking groundhog today.
Yeah, we're restarting today because we died.
I'm like going deep in the jungle.
I think I don't wanna live in Pride Rock anymore.
Wait, I'm hitting the invisible wall though!
No!
I don't understand.
Oh, is it because we talked to Timon and Pumbaa too fast?
The game was like, you're not supposed to talk to them yet.
Is this the jungle?
No, go talk to...
Wait, there's a black zebra!
Oh, it's just a gazelle.
Wait, aren't zebras originally black with white stripes?
I don't remember.
They shade the zebra and the white stripes are the fur.
Why are you laughing?
It's true!
What?
They are!
Why are you laughing?
Wait, I'm stuck behind an invisible wall.
I think I'm trapped for real.
Just use your magic wand.
Okay, I'm out.
Are you gonna go talk to...
Yeah, I'll talk to them again.
I think we broke the game.
I think we're never gonna see Mufasa die.
What?
They don't think children will sequence break?
Like, come on.
We'll never see Mufasa die.
That's fine.
It's literally the only thing I asked for.
That's okay.
I always wanted a brother.
Just like you.
No!
It's because we sequence break!
Wait, seriously?
I think so.
We're never gonna see Mufasa die.
I don't think they probably have him die.
I'm pretty sure we could have seen him die.
Like, why would he?
Why would he let you?
He would like dissolve into little Minecraft dust particles.
You know like the...
Minecraft story where the pig just...
What?
Have you ever seen a Minecraft...
Infamous Minecraft story from Telltale's game?
Where like the pig...
It was like an emotional moment and then the pig just fucking dies.
And turns into pork.
Wait, you've never seen that video?
Okay, wait.
I'm gonna kidnap a hyena real quick.
Oh, where'd you find one?
I'm in the hyena territory.
You know like...
The light doesn't touch us, don't go there.
Wait guys, how do you use this?
Do you know?
I can't believe you've never seen that video before.
It's so good.
I don't consume Minecraft content.
I'm kidnapping this hyena.
You're mine now.
Wait, what the fuck is this?
Why would the compass work?
Oh!
I found another thing.
Oh my god, I found the hyenas!
I found where they live.
It's an ability you don't have yet.
Oh, oh!
The hyena doesn't want to talk to me.
She's too good for me.
Oh, they're all like...
There's this ability we don't have yet.
I'm gonna send you the...
Oh, am I out of the game?
Did your game crash?
No, I remember what I said every time I tabbed out.
Oh my god.
I see.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm in the dressing room so I can show you.
Minecraft story pig.
I can't believe you've never seen this before.
It's so good.
It better be.
It better be really, really good.
It's actually...
It's so good.
It's one of the best scenes ever.
I'm kidnapping a hyena.
Are you kidnapping a hyena?
Oh my god, why is it four minutes long?
Why?
It's four minutes long!
We only have two more hyenas to kidnap.
Okay, I need to find...
I need to find the shortest video.
I can't...
Let's do Markiplier React.
Yeah.
Markiplier React.
I'm gonna kidnap another hyena.
What the hell is that?
Are you in the realm?
Oh my god.
God damn it.
Okay, I'm back in.
Where are you?
I'm in the realm.
I'm with the hyenas.
Me too.
I just saw you.
Wait, you're Steve again?
God damn it.
Don't worry.
I'll be Sans.
And then...
Yeah, you're Sans.
And then I'll be...
Oh wait, there's hyenas we can talk to down here.
No, they don't talk to you.
They don't acknowledge you.
Bastard.
You don't...
Hello?
Well, well, Banzai.
What have we got here?
I don't know, Shenzi.
But I'd say it's trespassers.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, wait.
We'd love you to stick around for dinner.
Yeah, maybe we could get those...
Well, you know...
Maybe you need to be more personable.
Oh my god.
I'm Pumbaa.
How much more personable can I be?
I'm rizzing them.
Maybe we could get those little lion cubs we saw to join us.
Except they're lying around.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I got one, I got one.
Make mine a cub sandwich.
What do you think?
I think I'm hungry.
All this talk of food has me starving.
Oh, me too.
Are you thinking what I'm thinking?
Dinner!
Is that it?
That's all they say?
Ed doesn't say anything.
That's not fair.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I just had to talk to her.
And then she talked.
You're Steve again.
I'm Steve again?
Yeah, I got kicked out.
Yeah, I tabbed out.
Guys, now I know why people don't play bedrock.
Ed doesn't do anything for me.
Alright, you know what?
Wait, should we do...
Let's try to go creative mode.
How do you do that?
Return to the hub.
What's the mode?
Create a mode.
No, I think I remember when you make this...
It doesn't allow you to add cheats.
Wait, really?
Yeah, because I tried to add them.
No, wait.
Oh, I can.
Oh, you can?
I have to be the operator, right?
What is it?
Mode...
Game mode...
I don't know how it is on bedrock.
Wait, what is it?
Slash game mode.
Cheats are allowed.
No!
Wait, I should be allowed to...
I think Disney is like...
Disney is like, no, no, no, you aren't gonna cheat.
No, no, no.
Why are you cheating?
No, no.
You know what?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna teleport to...
I'm gonna go to...
Cheats are fine and played on me.
Wait, I'm back in the hub.
Where did you go?
I'm in Lion King.
You're still there?
Yeah.
I'm here now.
Ok, I'll leave.
Is there nothing else to do here?
Oh wait, I can activate cheats?
How?
Wait, I think if we go into sandbox mode, maybe?
Wait, ok.
Oh, I activated friendly fire.
Oh, you did?
Wait, I found the last Aida!
I activated cheats.
Ok, uh...
Game mode...
Creative...
Your game mode has been successfully updated.
I'm flying.
What?
How do you do it?
In the jungle, the mighty jungle...
A lion sleeps tonight.
Where are you?
In the jungle...
The mighty...
Remember who you are...
Where are you?
Are you looking at me?
Oh wait, I see you.
Remember who you are...
Ok, game mode...
I'm gonna give you...
Let's see if I can give you...
Wait, where are you though?
Just go down.
Where are you?
I don't see you.
Turn around.
In the jungle...
I can't hurt you!
Yes!
Wait,
what happened?
Where did you go?
Wait, no, I'm still in the jungle.
Where did you...
We're trying to kill Mufasa.
Wait, can you?
I'll kill him now.
Wait...
Can you push him?
No, I'm doing something better.
In the jungle...
Long live the...
Look, he's begging for it.
He's breaking his neck to get it.
Long live the king...
Do it already!
Oh my god, he's...
He's invincible!
Wait, with this we might actually be able to push him to the...
To the gorge and then we can have him actually fall down and die.
Oh yeah, I definitely can get hurt from that.
How do we push him?
With the water.
Oh, with the water?
Ok, we gotta make a tunnel to it.
Where's the gorge?
It's over this way, I think.
Put him in a boat.
Oh yeah, a boat!
Can he like...
Ok, let me get the boat.
Mufasa, we're gonna recreate history.
It's not over there, something's glowing.
What is that, guys?
It's not glowing.
Oh my god, it's on the boat!
Wait, wait, wait.
Get rid of the...
What the heck?
Oh my god, I gotta get rid of this lava.
Use the bucket, use the bucket.
Oh, this is what this thing...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm stuck, I'm stuck.
Wait, wait, no, no, no.
Stop, stop!
Where did you go?
Oh god, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck.
Use your magic wand, use your magic wand.
I'm trying not to use it.
Ok, I'm fine.
Are you ok?
I don't think you're fine.
I'm fine, everything's good.
Alright, I'm ok too.
Get in the boat, Mufasa.
Get in the boat.
Oh my god, I think I fucked it up.
No, use water to push him in.
He's not getting on the boat, look at all the boats I have.
He's not getting in.
He's in, he's in, he's in, he's in!
And all it took was for me to show up.
Wait, can I get in the boat?
Here we go, here we go, here we go.
Come on Mufasa!
Let's go!
Let's go Mufasa, let's go!
Come on Mufasa, we're going to the gorge!
Come on Mufasa!
Let's go!
We've kidnapped the king!
We're gonna finish the job.
Do something Scar can never do.
Should we bring Scar?
No, he's too far I think.
We might bring Simba.
To watch his dad die.
Watch your dad die Simba, it's time.
Wait, I wanna be a pyre.
Don't worry, I'm coming over too.
How can we get him up to the top of the gorge?
Oh the water, I can bring water over.
Oh yeah, bring some water and I'll float up it.
Okay, okay.
Alright, here we go.
It's like in my face.
Don't worry, I'm bringing Simba too.
Simba.
I see you very slowly.
Wait, I can leash the boat.
Wait, I can?
Leash.
Wait, can I actually?
Simba.
Can I leash you up?
Oh, but you went inside one of these paths.
You can't go in here.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
It's time.
You row, I pour water.
Okay.
Oh, okay, there we go.
Wait, let's try the leash now.
Maybe it'll work.
Okay, maybe, yeah.
Does it work?
How do I leash him?
I think you leash the boat.
I don't think it works.
No, no, no, no.
You row, I water.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I want to go up higher.
It's time to watch your dad die, Simba.
Go to the top of that hill.
Up here.
And let the water run down.
And see if we can get up here.
Here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, come on, Mufasa.
Let's try going up.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no, Mufasa!
Mufasa!
Mufasa, too soon!
Too soon, Mufasa!
Stop!
Stop sending water!
No,
Mufasa, no!
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
I want him to fall from the absolute tallest spot.
I'm trying!
No more water!
No more water.
Okay, here we go, here we go.
Oh gosh, I was so close.
At least it didn't work, you guys.
I'm close, I'm close, I'm close.
Is he still with me?
No.
Get rid of some of the water!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Why am I going down with him?
You see that, Simba?
You see that?
Remember these faces, Timon and Pumbaa, who killed your dad!
We killed your dad, so now you can be your gay husband!
Oh my god!
Someone just said try TNT on...
What?
That's right, we killed your dad so we can adopt you.
That's right.
Get the TNT, get the TNT and blow him up.
Goodbye, Mufasa.
He looks like so desperate with his big teeth.
He looks like such a bozo.
I'm done saving you, Mufasa.
No!
Wait, wait, wait, can I go to the other side?
Hold on, I want to save him from the tower.
Pure cinema?
Yeah, pure cinema.
Alright, we'll know now.
I'll tell you when I'm there.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let me get to the top.
I'm slow, I'm slow.
It's all the water, it's all the water.
It's all the water.
This movie is different from what I remember.
Okay.
Doing what Scar couldn't.
Light her up.
I lit it up.
He lives!
Oh my god, he lives!
I thought it would like shoot him up into the air.
Yeah, me too, I thought so too.
Oh my god.
Well, that was great.
It was great visiting Lion King.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there's water.
There's water.
Wait, where's the water?
I'm pruning Africa down.
Goodbye, players.
Oh my god, they're just walking right through it.
Goodbye.
Wait, these aren't even real trees.
They don't even light up.
Wait, they're not even real trees.
Where are we?
Oh yeah, this is apparently a dream.
This is Disney magic.
That's what it is.
We're in Simba's nightmare right now.
This is what he plays except when he remembers his dad dying, but it also includes fire all around.
Fire and Timon and Pumba.
Wait, I can reset the world so we can do creative one versus the other ones.
Okay.
Alright, let me reset the world.
It's like nothing happened.
It's like we didn't terrorize the planes.
Yeah, we're in the Truman Show.
I'll reset the world.
I'll reset it.
Are you enjoying Minecraft?
Wait, so like, leave, leave?
Yeah, leave, leave and I'll reset it.
Let's see, how do I destroy this?
Okay, manage realm.
Oh my god, we have to wait.
Guys, this is my first time going through this.
Yeah, this is Kingdom Hearts 4.
Alright, let's see.
How do I destroy this world as if nothing happened?
As if we didn't kill everything.
Wait, can you just make a new realm?
Yeah, I could, yeah.
I want to destroy this realm though.
I don't want this realm anymore.
Oh wait, it's here!
You discovered the Badlands.
I assumed that was...
I assumed that one was like...
Yeah, that one's our realm.
How do I destroy you?
I want to destroy.
Edit world.
Fetching realm.
Uh...
Oh, I can restore the world!
To what it was like.
I don't want to restore.
I want to destroy it.
Fetching realm.
Do something!
I'm trying to figure it out!
Why doesn't it let me destroy you?
Okay, creating new.
Okay, play on realms.
Uh...
Here.
I did it.
I'm destroying the realm as if it never happened.
What we did...
It's like we never terrorized this area.
Delete the VOD.
Yeah, we didn't try to kill Mufasa.
We didn't.
I'm gonna change.
No one will know my crime.
I'm a solid creeper.
I don't know why I have these.
I didn't buy them, so I don't know why I have them.
Oh, solid creeper?
Yeah, I recreated it.
Alright.
Oh, you did?
Yeah, yeah.
Add realm members.
Invite.
Did you get it?
Let me see.
Alright.
It's like...
We didn't destroy this realm.
Wait, I love...
I'm gonna be a new skin.
You're gonna be a new skin?
Bonjour, mademoiselle.
It is with great pride.
Do the Tetris.
It's like...
I wanna be Disney too.
Let's see.
It is with great pleasure.
Oh, wait, I can change the set.
Wait, let me add...
What is it?
Friendly fire.
Okay.
Oh, did I not save it?
Do you see me?
Friendly fire.
Beast!
Oh my god, it's a beast!
Unlock all worlds, alright.
Unlock all worlds.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's going beast mode!
What just happened?
Oh my god, we unlocked everything.
Aladdin!
This is the record book.
Do you have that successfully executed six function entries?
No.
Why does it show up on my side?
Oh my god, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
This is a successfully...
Where does it show up?
On my chat.
I thought it was cause like...
Oh, function six is clocking someone in the face?
Oh, it's cause I hit you.
That's why I have it.
You hit me, I hit you too much.
Wait, how do you...
Oh, I have all the game info on?
How do I turn that off?
Wait, they're not all unlocked?
Wait, but they are.
But they are not.
That's weird.
They should be.
Yes.
Oh shit, sorry.
Where are we?
Oh, we're in Snow White!
The beast!
Oh my god, it's Gaston!
Oh, game.
Oh, it's cause I had this.
Game rule.
It's cause I had that.
Oh my god, what did I do?
There goes the beast ravaging the village.
Oh my god.
Every morning it's the same.
It's the morning that she came.
Poor girl Belle.
Oh my god.
I broke my game.
What did you do?
I'm trying to fix my game right now.
No!
Stop!
I broke my game!
If you die, you might be back to normal.
No!
That's not how it works!
I broke my game!
Lumiere!
No!
Stop!
Are you dying at all?
No, I don't know.
I'm trying to fix my game.
Right now!
No, I still can't get out.
Somebody fix my chat!
What are you talking about?
My chat!
It's broken!
Somebody fix my chat!
All I see is the game rules!
Oh my god.
What did I do?
How did this happen to me?
I'm going to kill you!
Don't worry!
You'll die!
You'll die and then you'll be reborn!
It's fine!
Don't worry!
I'll kill you!
Did it work?
You saw nothing.
No!
The beast!
It didn't work.
I don't know what's going on.
All I see is my chat.
My chat commands.
That's all I see.
Did you try escape?
Did I try escape?
There you are.
You look capable.
Join me.
We're going to storm the castle and slay the hideous beast.
Did he actually say that?
Yeah!
You're the beast.
So we can rescue the girl who's going to be my wife.
The most beautiful bell.
It will be your honor.
A mighty honor, I'd say.
Yes, LeFou.
Very mighty.
Meet me at the edge of the village.
We'll set out from there.
Onward!
Did we get to kill Gaston?
Are we going to kill him?
Bye, Gaston.
Bye.
Wait, what if I restart my game?
Restart your game.
What I see is like...
I can't see half my screen.
Oh my god.
She goes again.
I don't know when I broke the game.
I thought this was blood.
I thought this was blood spots.
Bonjour!
Bonjour, bonjour!
I need six eggs!
That's too expensive!
It must be more than this provincial life.
That's why I'm going to make Belle my wife.
That didn't work.
Oh there's our dad!
What the fuck was that?
Maurice!
Oh there he is.
Oh my god.
He looks like Goddamn.
Where are you?
I'm at the edge of the village.
Oh, I'm heading over there.
He looks like...
Herobrine over there.
What?
I'm gonna go into Belle's rooms and sniff her sheets.
You're gonna what?
What are you gonna do?
Where are you?
I'm trying to fix my game.
Still?
I don't understand.
She's the most beautiful girl.
Bella, you have to.
You only get one chance to do that.
Can I ride the horse?
Please.
Please, somebody.
Freebie!
Here, once you're good, I have a...
I have a ride for us.
Wait, are you in Belle's house?
Are you in here?
I'm heading over to Belle's house right now.
I see Belle's dad.
Wait, is that Belle's dad?
Yeah, that's Belle's dad.
Wait, where are you?
I do not see you.
Wait, I got a collectible.
I do too.
I already got that.
Wait, where are you?
I'm right in front of Belle's house.
Wait, they got another...
manual for me to travel.
Why is this so scuffed?
No, you have to see what I have to go through.
Your game is cursed.
Wait, I think it's fixed.
No, it's not.
I still don't see you.
I fixed it!
We
figured it out.
I'm on a horse right now.
Me too!
Wait, where are you?
Where are you?
I'm in front of Belle's house.
I'm in front of Belle's house too.
Hello?
Where are you?
You're here.
The beast?
Did you see Belle's dad?
I'm at the village farm.
Sorry, I'm not at her house.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, you're so far!
Where are you?
I'm gonna head over to Belle.
Okay, head over to Belle's dad.
Belle's dad?
Yeah, we gotta go talk to Gaston.
Oh, I see him!
Hello, Steve.
Hello.
Where am I, Steve?
Yeah.
Don't worry, the sign's gonna be here for a sec.
One sec.
And then...
There we go.
Bonjour.
Bonjour, bonjour, bonjour.
What does Belle's dad say?
I don't know, I didn't talk to him.
Oh no!
How on earth did that happen?
I'm about ready to give up on this hunk of junk.
I'll never get this boneheaded contraption to work.
That's all he says.
What did you change into?
Of course, Lumiere.
Look, this time we're not gonna sequence break.
So we're gonna experience the story.
I'll be LeFou.
Okay.
Oh, we can't leave just yet.
First I must go take care of old Maurice.
You go ahead and scout for us.
And then soon I will have Belle for my wife.
Make no mistake.
Oh, you don't get any lines.
I don't get lines.
Just like the real Maurice.
Let's take the horse.
But I can't ride the horse with you.
You can't?
Can I?
No, I can't.
We gotta get another horse.
There's another horse over there.
I saw another horse that we can steal.
This is the way to the castle.
Oh yeah, I see your horse.
Yeah, that's my horse.
You thought this was her dad?
Yeah, I thought that was her dad.
I was like, there's the dad.
With beautiful, red, luscious hair.
Totally what Belle is known for.
Her red, luscious hair.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She got the brown hair from the mom, right?
Wow, there's so many...
Wait, I'm going the right way, right?
Where are we?
I don't know, I'm looking at the map right now.
We're at the forest hills.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Oh, there it is!
The castle!
Oh, daddy's home.
Why are you in the ground?
The beast castle.
Alright.
There's Belle over there!
We did it, Gaston!
We killed the beast!
We did it!
The beast is down!
Can you give me creative for a second?
Just use your magic wand!
Right click!
Do you want to return to the hub?
I have to go all the way back.
No, left click, left click.
Just TP to Belle.
To the castle kitchen?
No, I don't want to...
Wait, hold on, I'll be there.
Oh my god, there's me!
Wait, hold on!
Wait for me!
We did it, everybody!
We killed the beast!
Kill the beast!
No, not me!
You got the wrong guy!
I'm his brother!
Can you bring your horse back?
So I have a horse to...
I have to ride the horse back to you?
And then what do I do?
There's gotta be like a third horse.
Just get over here.
I'm trying.
Am I going the right way?
I think there might be another way.
Wait, could I have gone this way?
Just open your map.
I'm going towards a mysterious path.
What the fuck do you mean a mysterious path?
Literally, the next thing is Belle.
Couldn't Disney have paid for properly looping music in this game?
I don't understand.
They literally just made like Minecraft music of the soundtrack.
I see your name.
I see you too.
This is like copyrighted Minecraft Beauty and the Beast music.
Yeah, it's like just legally distinct.
I just got someone with a really interesting name super chatting me.
And I want you to confirm or deny.
What is it?
Eating Doki Bird's ass.
They gave you money and not me?
They're too busy eating your ass.
I'm going to stand next to you and you won't know who's who.
Oh wait, I actually thought you were...
Wait,
can I ride that?
What do you mean, can I ride that?
Oh my God, there's a dresser.
You're Sonic running?
He can't ride the style.
I'll be Lumiere.
Gasp, do my eyes deceive me or do we have a guest?
Oh, you must be soaked to the bone.
Please, please come in.
You're me Cosworth.
Lumiere, what are you doing?
We can't let them go back out there.
Please, you must stay.
Be our guest.
He said the thing.
No, no, no.
The master won't like this at all.
Oh, Cosworth.
Have a heart.
Of course, they are welcome here.
Now, let us introduce you to our other esteemed guest.
Mademoiselle Belle.
She is just over there.
Where?
What does that mean?
She's under there.
Over here.
Wait, I think she's at the kitchen.
Oh, wow.
They put the woman in the kitchen?
Oh my God.
She's flexing on us.
Oh, it's a mini game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Be our guest.
Oh my God.
I bet you'd like a nice spot of tea.
It'll warm you up in no time.
Oh, that's it.
That's all she says.
Hey, wanna see me do a trick?
That's what he says?
Yeah, yeah, that's what he says.
And he does a flip.
What are you talking about, mama?
What's going on?
That might not be a cool trick, but can you do this?
I'm gonna talk to Belle.
Oh, hello.
It's very nice to meet you.
Are you a guest here as well?
Oh, I see.
Gaston has sent you to rescue me, has he?
Of course he'd never ask me what I want.
Well, you can tell him.
I'm not in any danger.
Though I doubt he'd listen.
Oh, you can be me, Belle.
I don't think we can finish your surprise dinner in time.
Our ideas may have been a bit ground.
We would need more help in the kitchen.
Oh, and do we have another guest?
Yes, I'd hope they'd join us.
Oh, but you're right.
It is getting awfully late.
Hmm...
I think I have an idea.
What if I help as well?
I've read through the recipe book after all.
Oh my god.
Perhaps you could help us too.
We could really use another pair of hands.
I could read out the instructions while you help with the preparations.
Oh boy, we're good at that.
Oh yeah, we're so good at reading instructions.
It's not like we just sequence break the last one.
The horse just walked in.
He just walked in.
From like the corner of my eye.
He's like, I'm hungry.
Oh my god.
How hungry.
Alright, yeah, let's cook a meal.
Wonderful, let's get started.
Okay, Belle will tell you what to cook.
Why does she keep flexing on us?
I know, what is she doing?
She's styling on us.
I'll tell you which ingredients.
Go and take the recipe, then you can prepare them and place them.
On the dishes.
Use ingredients on cooking.
What the hell, is this overcooked?
Yeah, I was thinking too.
Lumiere will be waiting to take the plates to the dining room.
Oh my god.
Do they need to eat their inanimate objects?
Yeah, but Belle needs to eat.
Oh no, first, shall we...
This calls for baked cheese.
Where's cheese?
Okay, and put it in the oven.
Why does the master have to make food?
Wait, what do I do?
Put it in the oven?
Yeah, that's the oven, right?
That looks like an oven.
Oh my god, it's actually playing the song!
Wait, is it?
Oh, it is!
What is the...
Wait, I think it shows us up here.
Oh, we're supposed to...
She makes...
This is fun!
What do I do?
Oh, I have some cheese for you!
I did it!
Oh my god!
Grab an apple and combine it with the wheat.
I'm already doing it!
Oh wait, we each...
Wait, we do our own things.
Are we competing?
Oh my god!
No, you took my wheat!
I thought we were working together!
I thought we were working together too!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's voices!
I'm too distracted!
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, ok.
Did that work?
Uh...
Pot...
Pitcher...
That's a person.
Oh my god, that's messed up.
Wait, where's the pitcher?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, huh?
Huh?
Where's the... Oh, here.
Oh, and this.
What's the other thing that I'm getting?
Oh, spices.
Ok, I got it.
I figured it out.
Wait, you already did it?
Oh my god.
Is that me?
What is that?
There I say!
That was magical!
It was rather fun.
And we must thank our new friend for the help...
Friend?
Oh my god, look at her hips.
Holy shit.
I can't believe they actually started singing.
It's because you don't have real plates.
And you only use paper plates.
I don't think we could have done it without you.
What?
It still keeps going.
Bella keeps talking.
Oh, now it's time for dinner.
But if you'd like to help us practice these recipes again, just let us know.
What is all this?
And what are they doing here?
Bella?
It's alright.
There's no need to worry.
Our new friends...
Helped us prepare this feast.
For you.
A feast?
For me?
Yes.
I wanted to thank you for helping me escape from those wolves.
It was my pleasure.
I was worried about how to invite you to dinner.
But I graciously accept.
Shall we eat?
Alright, let's go eat.
Let's go eat.
Oh my god, wait, they're in here.
Oh my god, what is this dress?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Hey, brother!
He's so much bigger than you!
Who's the real beast?
Who could it be?
I want to do something special for Bella.
I've never felt this way about anyone before.
Girl, what are you doing?
What do we do next here?
Do we just talk to them?
I think this game might have been a scam.
Is that it?
There has to be... Is that it?
Does it not...
When do we kill the beast?
That doesn't actually happen in the story.
I want to kill the...
Oh, there's the horse.
Our horse went here.
I want to know when we can kill the beast.
Kill the beast.
Does the game part end when we get to the mini game?
Yeah, I think there's like two dialogues and that's it.
Oh my god, we'll never kill the beast.
Where is the horse?
Oh, he's in the library.
There's a library?
Oh my god.
He wants to get educated.
Oh, I see you.
Wait, there's more here?
Where does this go?
I want to find the beast's room and then destroy his rose.
Yeah, we got to destroy the rose.
Destroy the... I found it!
Wait, wait, wait.
I want to see it.
I found it.
Is it up more?
Yeah, it's up here.
Watch, I'll do something crazy.
No, I see you.
Hold on.
Oh shit.
Watch.
Do you see this rose?
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh.
There's a watermelon under here!
It's gone now.
What?
And thus the beast shall die.
Why is it melon?
Oh my god.
This place is full of cobwebs.
I mean, it's old.
Look, the rose is gone.
I did it.
Whoa.
Yeah, you did it.
I'm proud of you.
I did it.
We did it.
We destroyed the beast's home.
Land on that...
Did you say hole?
Home.
And thus my job here...
Wait, wait, wait.
Look at me.
Where are you?
Look, I'm here.
I'm proud of you.
My job here is done.
I thought you were gonna jump off.
Wait, I wonder...
Oh my god.
It's your brother.
Wait, I'm gonna be a gargoyle?
My job here is done.
Do I look good?
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
You look just like him.
Which one's the real gargoyle?
Wait, there's a...
There's a garden in the back.
Wait, is there?
You wanna be creative mode?
Okay, okay, okay.
Game mode, creative...
Wait, what's your...
What's your full name?
Made Mint Phantom, I think.
Made Mint Phantom creative.
Did you get it?
Oh, I didn't.
Wait, how do I give you creative?
Uh, slash...
What is it?
Game mode?
Uh...
Creative...
Made...
Oh, here you go.
Yeah!
Now we can zoom everywhere.
What's this?
A book?
That is a collectible.
You know, silly Belle, leaving her stuff around.
I'm gonna destroy this castle.
Kill the beast!
I know he's got treasure in the basement!
He's gotta have treasure in the basement!
Oh, the melons are back!
Why is there melons in his home?
Oh, it's like the tiles.
It's the green tiles.
They used melon for it.
Oh...
Alright, I'm going.
Kill the beast!
I'm going into the basement.
Are we bad people?
No...
I'm trying to get into this hole.
Maybe they'll have like...
Prisoners down there.
Let's see.
I'm gonna kill Gaston.
Just for the sake of it.
Where are you, Gaston?
I can't believe it.
We don't actually get to kill the beast.
What's the point?
Come on, guys.
Torch.
There we go.
We're more villainous than Disney villains.
Where are you, Gaston?
Oh my god, you're still down there?
Where did you dig to?
Where are you?
Surely there's treasure down here.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Into the void.
Into the unknown.
Yeah, where's Frozen World?
I found the basement.
Nothing but the abyss.
Into the unknown.
That's where they send the prisoners.
Right here, sir.
This is where they are.
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh, there I am.
Can I save my horse now?
I don't know.
I don't know where your horse is.
He's down here.
He's a bit further than before.
I wonder what the collectible is here.
Explore all areas.
Find the hidden books.
Assist Belle.
Oh yeah, we got most of everything.
Yeah, we got everything.
We basically finished this world.
I'm going back to the hub.
I'm just exploring a little bit.
I don't think there's anywhere to explore.
This is where like...
This is the edge of the world.
Who the hell is this farmer?
I'm gonna burn the village.
Burn Gaston.
Upcoming fact.
What the hell?
I'm Alter Lumiere.
I'm here to burn the village.
You try to kill the beast.
I'll kill the world.
Hold on.
I can send him.
Please.
Oh shit.
I know how to kill Gaston.
Wait, what?
Wait, what happened?
What are you doing?
Wait,
he has a task for us.
Why does he have an excavation point?
No, he doesn't.
It was just going to the beast.
We know how to kill Gaston.
Wait, I can't see anything.
Oh shit, where is he?
We know what to do now.
I'll go down first.
And then, I believe you're here.
And I'll dig up with you.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Goodbye, Gaston.
He's so dreamy.
Gaston.
Rest in peace.
I went down your hole.
I picked the wrong hole.
There he goes.
Goodbye, Gaston.
We could send the whole village down here.
Can you do this?
What are you doing?
Can we TP all?
TP all?
TP all NPCs?
Is that TP...
Oh, it doesn't work.
Oh, we gotta try.
This is where he went.
TP...
Oh my god, I know there's one where you can...
Oh, at all entities.
Oh my god!
You're gonna break the game for real!
But...
Will he kill him?
Oh no.
Oh my god!
Did I do it?
Did I break the game?
Where are you?
What happened?
Did I break the game?
Oh wait, wait, wait!
I'm here too!
Where are you?
I
don't know what happened!
The beast is no more.
The beast is no more!
What is that?
Oh hello.
Let me change my clothes.
We gotta dress for the occasion.
I'm dressing for the occasion.
Me too!
Which one are you gonna be?
Don't wear my same outfit.
Alright, I'm turning around.
Where are you?
Alright, let's go commit some wishes.
Why is this world's volume so much louder?
Wait, we can go get all the treasure!
Oh true!
Oh my god, let's free ourselves!
We don't need Aladdin!
We can free ourselves!
Alright, let's go.
We have what we call creative mode.
We're rich!
Abu, don't touch it!
Don't touch the stuff.
Don't touch it, Abu.
Oh my god.
We can be Aladdin.
Oops, I didn't mean to grab this.
Yeah, break that.
Oh, I can't.
You can't break it.
We can send it to the...
Into the unknown!
Can your friend do this?
Can your friend do...
Can your friend do that?
Can your friend do this?
That's the same thing!
Why can't we go into the hole?
There we go.
Alright, here we go!
Into the unknown!
Oh my god.
How fast have you dug?
I've already dug.
We're free!
We don't need Aladdin.
Aladdin will never get this down.
That's right.
We're not chained to nobody.
We're free genies now.
We're free genies.
You're so stupid.
I'm breaking out of here.
I'm digging up.
I'm not going to be trapped here.
I don't know where I ended up.
I'm outside of bounds.
Don't dig up.
I'm right here.
There's an invisible wall.
I broke it.
That's right.
Nothing can block us.
We're invincible now.
Powerful genies!
Where's the sultan?
I'm going to kidnap the sultan.
Give us the throne.
Or we'll send you to the void.
He's crying.
Yeah, look at him.
Look, look, look.
He's like, that's right, be afraid.
Wait, what if I do this?
Watch this.
Give us the throne or I'm going to shoot you.
Why can't...
That's right.
Give us the throne or I'll shoot.
Alright, sultan.
What are you doing?
I'm poisoning him.
Oh my God.
I'm poisoning the throne.
Wait, go out of creative.
Okay, okay.
See if it works.
Game mode adventure.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, it doesn't work?
What the hell?
No, you didn't poison me.
No!
I've been lied to.
Oh, you know, like, one thing I'm...
One thing I pride myself on, I'm an excellent judge of character.
Somebody said?
That's right.
Go inside.
Where did you go?
I'm looking for Jafar.
I wonder if we...
What is the tiger's name?
I forgot.
Wait, where did you go?
I'm outside.
Are you with Jasmine?
No, I think she's at the beginning.
No, she's right here.
Where?
Wait, there's a magic carpet.
Are you in her room?
No, no, no.
I'm right here.
Where's the tiger?
Over here.
Someone says Raja.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Oh my God, he's so cute!
Hello, Raja.
Alright, show me Jasmine.
Okay, she's like...
Call me Gelatin.
Gelatin?
Have you ever seen that song?
No!
That's Aladdin and Jasmine.
Let me break this invisible wall.
Wait, how do we...
Why is there an invisible wall?
I guess we're not allowed to fly.
Wait, how do we access this?
I think we have to talk to Jasmine back there.
To access this.
Let me talk to her.
Alright, Jasmine, we need you to head over there...
so we can activate your game.
Yeah.
Oh, there he is, yeah.
Where's Aladdin?
Welcome to Agrabah, my name is Jasmine.
It's probably in a town.
Aladdin, right?
The magic carpet droops down sadly.
Magic carpet ride.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, I see her, I see her.
She's already here.
A whole new world!
I'm gonna stay in Adventure.
Where is Aladdin?
Activate the game.
That guy is blonde with blue eyes.
I don't think he belongs here.
Are you lost, buddy?
Alright, I'm talking to Jasmine.
Okay.
Alright, hey you scoundrel.
Did you steal that apple?
Of course not, we're only talking.
The scoundrel probably ate it.
No one steals from my cart.
Thief!
Alright.
Okay.
Ride on the magic carpet to escape from the angry shopkeepers.
You need to steer in the right direction.
Wait, are we both on the magic carpet?
No.
I just... wait.
I think it's a one person game.
Wait, is this a one person?
Reach the end to win?
Wait, are you racing?
I don't think...
You see this instruction?
I only...
I had to...
Zoom through the text.
Oh no, I think...
Wait, I'm stuck in the loading screen.
Yeah, me too.
I think we broke the game.
Yes!
Is our Disney tour over?
Is it because we didn't properly load into this world?
I think so.
I think it's because we deleted the pizza.
We deleted the castle.
Move!
I want to ride the magic carpet.
No, I want it to be a whole new world.
Let's quit.
I'm going to quit.
And I'm going to join again.
Yeah, me too.
We just want to go to a whole new world.
I want to ride the magic carpet.
We can at least do all the minigames.
I'm back!
I got the obstacle.
Do we just go?
Wait.
Okay, I'm in game mode.
Maybe we have to be on adventure, both of us.
I'll give it to you.
Wait, there's Abu!
Are you in the minigame?
No, I'm in.
Are you in the lobby?
I just discovered a secret room.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, you just dropped me!
I can't get out.
I was a spectator.
Far beneath the ground.
Okay, I'm good.
Okay, where are you?
Is that you?
Where are you?
Are you holding a book?
Yeah, I'm holding a book.
You are invisible to me.
Look!
Wait, can you go into spectator mode?
Can you put us both in spectator?
I need to show you.
I need to show you where I went.
Why are we invisible?
It's like a magic trick.
Okay, now go below...
Do you see the two hidden rooms?
Why is there red in the fucking room?
And I was trapped in here.
I was trapped in here.
It was literally my grave.
Thank you for the red.
Thank you so much.
Good.
Wait, I see the blonde man.
Where is he?
I don't think the game is any better.
I think it's still messed up.
I think we messed up.
Wait, put us back to adventure.
And then we'll...
Put us back to adventure and we can just...
Take us back to the hub.
Okay, okay.
Adventure.
I didn't see Aladdin.
I don't know what happened to him.
He just disappeared.
Disappeared.
Where did you go?
Are you going back to the hub?
Yeah, I want to go back to the hub.
Wait, you cannot tell...
We're stuck in the game.
I'm starting the game.
Wait, how do you start the game?
We broke the game.
We actually broke the game.
We were never supposed to be here.
Wait, is that you?
I see a magical path.
I don't know what that is.
We broke the game.
We were supposed to ride on the magic carpet.
It didn't give us a magic carpet.
But they did.
I've been slowed.
What do you mean you've been slowed?
Apparently, if you hit a wall, you get slowed.
How did you get a magic carpet?
I don't know.
I'm running the course.
No!
Wait, what's happening?
I can't move.
Wait, I'm starting the race!
We're starting the race!
Guards arrived?
What does that mean?
Are we on a carpet?
I think we're just running.
Oh no, how am I going to get over there?
No!
I have to restart because I...
I broke...
Be careful!
I made it!
I ran through the one hole I dug.
No, no, no!
That's not what happened.
I
can have the carpet.
Wait, are you on the carpet?
I hit the right click, the carpet!
I just watched you.
I didn't realize.
It's so unfair.
I'm doing this again.
I'm doing...
I literally watched you...
I literally watched you drop the carpet.
And you kept going.
Wait, what am I supposed to do?
I'm in tears.
What?
It's so slow!
I don't think you can touch anything with it.
Or rather, you can't press space or...
Bro, why am I so slow?
Oh god.
I'm crying.
I can't see the track between my tears.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it.
We can talk to the carpet.
Yeah, he just restarts the world.
Where's Aladdin in all of this?
I don't know, we saw his monkey, we saw a bull.
We saw a bull, we saw...
We didn't see Jafar though, but like...
Where the fuck is...
Where the fuck...
In Agrabah, there's no Aladdin?
What the hell?
What the fuck, where are we?
We're on the racetrack.
Arabian Nights.
I think we actually destroyed...
Wait, I'm gonna check if Belle's world is still back.
I'm TP back, I need to know.
Oh, I broke all the portals.
Wait, what do you mean you broke all the portals?
Wait, come back.
None of the portals.
Wait, what if we use the staff to teleport to one of the minigames?
Let's go to...
Let's go to Maze Chase.
They kicked us out, I think they closed the portals.
They can't stop us.
Oh, I've been to Alice in Wonderland.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
So this works?
Oh yeah, we gotta change worlds.
The borders will stop us.
They really think you can't stop us from coming here.
We'll always find a way.
You fucked it in two hours, but Organization 13 couldn't do.
You just get us in, Kingdom Hearts will finish.
We won't even have Kingdom Hearts 4, the game will finish in Kingdom Hearts 1.
You will kill Sora.
Where are you?
I'm right behind you.
You're invisible to me.
Oh no, you're not invisible.
Maybe if I change skins.
Oh, I just hit you.
Oh yeah, I see you.
Alright.
Okay, there we go.
Oh wait, Autobot, Autobot.
Oh wait, Autobot, you're right.
Alright, do you like my bow?
Yeah.
You're a shark cat with a gun.
This feels on brand for the Mad Hatter.
Yeah, it does actually.
A very unbirthday to you.
To you.
So, when I was in grade school...
No, middle school.
Also, why is the music in here so intense?
But when I was in middle school, I wanted to be the Mad Hatter for my school's Halloween.
Yeah.
Why'd you leave?
Oh wait, I tabbed out.
So my mom got me a costume, but it was one of those sexy costumes that said like...
Oh my God!
His hat said 69 over 420.
Am I a shark cat or am I Steve?
You're Steve.
Okay, I gotta re-wear my clothes again.
I didn't know what it meant until my mom, or not my mom, my teacher told me what it meant.
Oh.
Wait, if it's a sexy costume, then like, wouldn't it be like, sexy?
I wore like, a tank top and stuff underneath it so nothing would show.
Alright, ever since I arrived...
Okay, you can be Alice.
Hello, I'm Alice.
I do hope you're someone who is sensical.
Ever since I arrived here, so much has been nonsense.
Oh, but you do seem as though you are what you are rather than being not what you are not.
Perhaps you might help me.
I fear I may have angered the Queen.
You see, she sent her playing card guards...
Oh my gosh, that is so hard to say, playing card guards.
To chase me through this maze.
Would you help me find a way out?
Oh, thank you.
Quick, we must find an exit.
Alright, what do we do?
We collect paint.
Wait, the leaves are disappearing.
Yeah, I know, the leaves...
Wait, how are we gonna do the maze if the leaves are disappearing?
We paint the roses to unlock the path.
Avoid the card soldiers, okay?
Wait, this is scary.
Yeah, this is scary.
What if they jump scare us?
Get to the end to win...
Why are the leaves disappearing?
Did somebody paint the roses already?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh god.
Oh, we're competing!
Sin Wonderland...
Wait, oh, did I not get the paint?
Oh, you have to right click the paint.
How do you get to Wonderland?
Do you just have to...
Oh my god, they're coming.
We're not competing.
Yes, we are.
How do you know?
We have the same score.
Because we haven't found the exit yet.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
I know where you are, so I...
Do you just paint any rose?
I'm so confused.
I guess so.
This is kind of weird.
I don't know where I am.
There's no more paint.
They're only chasing after me.
This is messed up.
I beat the game.
Sin Wonderland...
Wait, what?
Where are you?
Where am I?
Oh, there's more paint.
Where did I go?
I don't know.
I broke the game.
No, you didn't.
Oh, I made it out.
I actually made it out.
I'll give you a creative move.
I'll show you where I went.
Okay, okay.
I was like, how did I get here?
I actually...
I actually won the game.
Okay, follow me.
Follow me.
I'm breaking this wall.
Break it, break it.
Break the wall.
Okay, so I...
I ran this way.
So obviously we have to go here, right?
This is where we have to go.
But like, I went...
Watch, follow me.
I went this way.
And then there was a hole right here.
And...
You went through here.
And then I was like...
And then I went all the way.
Follow me.
I went all the way.
I was like...
What?
Wait.
Oh my god.
I was like, I did it.
And I was like, wait, this is a secret.
Why would they even let you in here?
I don't know.
I literally was like running through these black maze.
And I was like, oh my god, I did it.
The music here is so crazy.
Why did it go black?
I was so confused.
Let me in.
I didn't realize...
I was not even in the game.
Why is it so intense?
Oh, cute.
Wait, the flower area is so cute.
Oh, yeah, it is.
You can talk to the flowers.
You can learn a lot of things from the flowers.
Or especially in the month of June.
Where are you?
We're like, I'm in the garden.
I'm trapped.
Wait, where are the flowers?
I want to talk to the flowers.
Go into the flower forest.
Oh, there they are.
Look at them.
Oh, where is the Mad Hatter place?
Oh, you're right.
Oh, there's Alice.
Alice.
Did I find them?
Oh, I found it.
Where?
I found it.
It's a tea party.
It's next to the gardens.
What the hell is the gardens?
It's next to the flowers.
Look up.
Up?
Look at me.
Do you remember?
I remember.
Okay, I need to talk.
I don't know what you're going to say.
Holy shit.
Sorry.
I didn't think the whole table would slip.
Oh my god.
You ruined their party.
I ruined their party.
I'm sorry.
It's a low-rise table.
It's fine.
I'm so excited.
You must have a couple of these.
Clean cup.
Move down.
Oh my god.
That poor door mouse.
Where is the door mouse?
Oh my god.
I didn't even see him in there.
You ruined their unbirthday.
It's his grave now.
You don't even see him anymore.
Goodbye, door mouse.
Goodbye.
We're sorry.
Menace.
I can't control my strength.
This is why...
They closed the borders.
They didn't want us to come back.
The other world heard about us.
What's his name?
Yeah, with the seashell people.
We're the little children that he enslaved.
Okay.
Look.
Oh wait, nevermind.
Wait, there's the door.
Wait, is this the door?
What door?
Oh, I'm late!
I'm so late.
Oh my god, I broke the door.
Where are you?
I'm still by the tea house.
Float up.
Floating up.
Go to the green forest.
Where are you?
Green forest.
Oh, I see you.
Right here.
Come here.
There's a rabbit.
Oh, he's late for a very important date.
So this was originally like...
Blocked up and I just...
Fucking destroyed it.
I was like...
It's my world now.
We can float on everything.
I think that's how you start the world.
Probably.
Yeah, I think we fall down here.
And then we're gonna be like...
Before they close the borders...
I'm sorry.
That's right.
We're here to invade your land.
They're like, oh god, don't give me...
Shut it out!
Shut everything down!
I heard they snatched...
The peace world out of existence.
Wait, if you go back...
To the beast world, is there anything?
Wait, how do we...
Let's try...
Castle kitchen.
Oh!
I'm here!
Does it still exist?
Everybody's gone though.
There's no people.
Wait, they might be in the void!
They might be in the void!
I'm gonna go down!
I think we killed them all!
I think we killed them!
No!
Go to the village!
The gargoyles left!
Now I know why they killed them.
Now I know...
Oh my god, we're the beast!
Oh my god, nobody's here!
Nothing is here!
Wait, horse fell out of the world!
Wait, people are falling out of the world!
Everybody got Thanos!
Why is this door open?
I don't know...
I don't think it would...
I'm breaking it!
Oh my god, it's so empty!
Everybody's dead!
I say bonjour, but no one says bonjour back!
Bonjour!
It's a ghost village!
Wait for me!
I'm gonna drown myself here for my sins!
Now I know why they closed the border!
Oh, did you set the village on fire?
Hide the evidence!
We gotta burn down the village!
50,000 people used to live here, now it's a ghost town!
Why doesn't it work?
Oh, I don't think you can burn this part of the village.
You know, that's a good way to end.
You know, I think this is a good way to...
To call it a year.
Yeah, I think so.
You know, we should go to Disney World next.
We won't break Disney World.
We'll do Disney World next time.
Yeah, we'll do Disney World next.
Yeah, we'll do Disney World next time, guys.
What a wonderful Disney adventure, everybody.
We wiped out...
We did what Kingdom Hearts couldn't.
We wiped all darkness away.
We wiped out the Disney World.
I can't believe that everybody's dead.
It's a wonder we got kicked out to Agrabah.
I know.
They deported us to Agrabah after what we did.
They're like, they'll die in the desert.
We did it.
We killed them all.
We killed Belle.
And the Beast.
That's right, Gaston.
We did it.
Put me in adventurer mode.
Alright, it's time we do it together.
Yeah.
For our sins.
Remember what we did, Mint.
I remember.
Do you remember?
I'll never forget.
I'm gonna do a flip.
Do the Tetris dance.
Wait, can I Tetris Evo?
I think you did it.
I think you did the Tetris Evo while we fell.
You go first.
I didn't fall very far.
Me too.
We should've done it in the void.
You know what?
We can go to the void.
We actually can.
Wait, I'm not dying.
We can only die in the void.
Okay, let's go die.
I think it's this way.
This is how I wanna go.
We're going all the way down.
Wait, is that not...
I think we have to go down to go up.
No, I see it.
I found it.
Alright.
I remember the hole you dug.
I remember your sins.
I was just trying to protect the village from Gaston.
Wait, I wanna go to Gaston's hole.
You go to this hole, I go to Gaston's hole.
And then we'll jump at the same time.
Okay, I believe in us.
Hold on, give me a second.
I gotta run there.
What a way to end it.
We saw the horses die.
It said on the side they died out of the world.
So I guess everybody else did too.
I think...
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm almost there.
What a way to go.
I'm waiting.
Okay.
Ready?
3, 2, 1...
Do you see the minigame?
Wait, what?
Respawn.
Wait, wait, wait.
Come to my hole.
I think I found everybody.
We have to go in creative mode.
Are they all in the...
Come, come, come.
Okay, alright, come on.
Oh my god.
No way.
Can I just drop?
Oh my god.
What is this?
It's a party!
I think...
Because there is a book from the beginning.
Wait, you are in the portal?
Oh my god.
Where did you end up?
It's just back in the town.
No, I'm in Snow White.
She wants a hug.
Oh my god.
I went to Snow White.
Wow, what a great...
What a way to end the collab.
Well, we found out why it broke.
We found out how we broke the game.
Next time we'll go to Disneyland.
Yay!
Oh man, that was fun.
Yeah, it was fun.
I hope you guys had fun too.
I was like, this is where all the Disney characters go when they die.
Don't let Mentor Jokey find you.
You'll be sent to the Shadow Realm every time.
We'll send you to the Shadow Realm.
We'll send you to where the Heartless go.
Oh my god.
Someone in super chat is like, I'm going to tell my kids that this was the real Kingdom Hearts.
Yeah, this is the real Kingdom Hearts.
This is how you only make one game for Kingdom Hearts.
We get the job done.
Yeah.
We really did do a good job.
GG's meant GG's.
Next time we'll do Disney World.
Yeah, you can ride the rides in Disney.
Yeah, I saw that.
And play the games at the rides too.
Yeah.
We explored all the worlds.
There's Snow White and Little Mermaid, right?
Yeah, there's still Little Mermaid.
I forgot about that one.
To be fair, we got the fun ones.
I think we did a pretty good job.
Who cares about Snow White or Little Mermaid anyway?
Who cares about them?
The water levels always suck.
Because Snow White is a dumb bitch.
What do you have against Snow White?
What did she do to you?
Her movies are boring.
Movies?
She has one!
Sorry, the next movie I can already tell.
There's a live action.
To be fair, did you hear that line?
The live action made a lot of movies.
Made a lot of money.
The Brother one?
Sonic.
They made more money than Sonic.
No!
It's only because it's Disney.
That's so true.
No!
I found the hole.
I found the Gaston hole.
Come see what you teleport to.
It's a gacha.
It's like a little gacha that we play.
There it is.
Alright, where am I gonna go now?
Where's the evil queen?
It's not teleporting me.
I'm in Snow White?
Am I Snow White?
Oh, I am in Snow White.
There's the birds.
I see the dark forest.
There's no evil queen.
And there's no place where Snow White dies.
To be fair, there wasn't even a place for Mufasa to die.
No, they had the gorge!
They had the gorge.
We had to create our own destiny.
I see you, I see you.
I'm behind you.
I found the queen's castle.
Yeah, but she's not in here.
Maybe she's somewhere where she's making the potion.
Oh, the evil area.
Yeah, the evil lair.
Maybe.
We'll never know.
I'm doing spectator mode.
I'm finding the evil queen.
Okay.
Game mode, spectator...
There we go.
Where are you?
Wait, there's a dungeon!
There's a dungeon?
Is she down here?
No, she's not.
How do you get in here?
I don't know, I just...
I just zoomed.
Oh wait, there's a little staircase.
Oh, there is.
X-ray on...
I found her!
She's here!
Look.
Oh my god!
She's with the mirror!
Yeah, the mirror on the wall.
Who's the dumbest of them all?
He's looking at you.
Ducky bird.
Okay, GG for real.
Disney adventure that we had.
This was truly an adventure.
Truly an adventure that will tell our children...
and our children's children...
and Dragoon's children's children...
What the hell, there's turtles?
Yeah, this is the real Disney experience.
This is the real Disney experience.
This is the real Kingdom Hearts right here.
Yeah, this is how I remember it, actually.
I know, me too.
A flower forest?
Where did Snow White die?
Um...
She died...
Well, she like, eats the apple...
and then I think she falls off the cliff...
and then she's put in the glass case.
Oh, I found the mines.
Hi-ho!
There's words there?
No.
That's how I remember it.
Wait, why don't they use...
actual Minecraft, like...
Ores.
Where's diamonds?
Where the fuck is diamonds?
They're not making any money.
I like how the little...
gemmies in this world look like the...
thing from The Sims.
Oh my God, there they are.
Oh my God, they're huge!
I found the dwarves!
Why are the dwarves as big as Snow White?
Where are they?
Go to the...
slash TP.
There, look.
They're just as big...
They're just as big as Snow White.
Holy...
Oh my God, the bird's trying to escape out of fear.
They're like...
Let me out!
Wait, that means...
I was like, why is his nose doing that?
Oh my God, they have different lengths of noses.
Look, it's not about...
the size of the nose, it's how you use it.
Which one's the real one?
Wait, he's bigger than you.
This is the first time he's bigger.
Oh my God!
Yeah, why are the dwarves bigger?
Is it because I'm in the ground?
No, you're...
No, they're still bigger than you.
Where are you?
I'm here.
You're invisible to me.
Oh no.
Are you in the house?
Yeah.
Oh well.
The bird just opened the door and flew inside.
Oh, that's you?
Yeah.
You're the bird?
No, I opened the door and the bird came in.
It looked like the bird opened it.
I thought you turned into a bird.
Oh my God, Morty.
Look, I turned into a bird.
I'm Doki Bird!
Look Morty!
The funniest shit in the world!
I'm Doki Bird!
Okay, I'm gonna...
I guess that's it then.
GG.
GG's, man.
Have a great time.
Next time, let's do this again soon.
Yeah.
And go to Disney World.
Yeah, and let's not destroy Disney World.
I mean, we could.
We could destroy it.
You know, at the end.
Oh yeah!
We should go into creative when the fireworks are about to go off.
And then put a lot of TNT everywhere.
If we go underground, you think we'll see Walt Disney Frozen?
Oh my God, you're right!
We'll see Walt Disney Frozen.
Cryogenic Chamber.
Yeah!
We'll see his head down there.
GG's, man.
GG's.
I'll see you next week.
Next week?
Oh yeah, that's right.
Surprise!
Next week we have another collab.
Another collab!
With the Sloppy Sisters.
See you next week, man.
Okay, see you next week!
Bye bye, GG!
Oh wait.
Are you gonna go talk to your chat?
I'm still on screen.
Just really fast.
Just gonna say bye.
Oh, you're gonna talk to your chat?
Yeah, just fast.
GG's, bye bye!
Oh, she sent me that video.
Markiplier reacts to Ruben's death.
Is this the pig you were talking about?
Oh, there's Doki.
I can't emote in spectator.
Let me emote!
Oh, okay, cool.
Of course!
Get out of the way!
Oh my gosh, we lost all our items!
Wait, so...
Wait, wait...
Did you also lose...
all your items?
This is why it's so stucky.
Wait, are we actually stuck here?
Juan...
Yeah?
We...
can't go back to the hub.
How'd she leave the realm?
Oh, she left the realm.
The realm.
Wait a second.
Wasn't the...
The entrance was...
Oh, here, here, here.
Maybe we can go back.
Is this the entrance?
Oh, Mr. Cute Jaguar.
Also, thank you, maid.
What?
Maid.
Thank you, maid.
Oh, hey Doki.
I went back.
Why'd she keep joining and leaving?
I just wanted to look around just a little bit more.
This world is actually...
Even though we...
broke all of it, it's actually...
Come on, seriously?
You won't let us go in here?
Only YouTube can break a world that was designed for kids.
Makes it a fun stream.
I hope you guys had fun!
Oh my god.
What's going on over here?
Oh, okay.
It just didn't load in.
I was like, what else did we break?
I hope you guys had fun!
And...
Oh, there's silly antics.
Truly...
Truly a Doki Mint adventure.
A genuine...
Genuine bonafide adventure.
I'm going to call you guys Organization 2.
I was... I cried so much from this.
Not gonna lie.
I was literally in tears.
Laughing.
Especially at the...
Especially with the magic carpet ride.
Glad for all your adventures.
Thank you guys!
And enjoy the rest of your...
Night, evening, whatever time it is for you.
Tomorrow!
Is Valentine's Day.
And I'm not done with my...
Making my stream yet.
I'm nervous.
Because I still have to...
I have literally everything to record.
I forgot to record that one thing today.
Oh no.
Maybe I'll have time to do it tomorrow.
Oh my gosh.
Just a little disclaimer.
It might be a little...
Spookier than...
People anticipate.
I even put like a disclaimer.
Because I feel like the last time I did a spooky stream...
People were like...
It's kind of scary.
So I was just like...
You know, just in case.
There's no jump scares or anything.
But it might be a little...
Spookier for some people.
So...
It's summoning a ghost after all, right?
But yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh my gosh, this is just like the library of everything...
Of the world that sent us to hell.
Where it all went wrong.
Oh god, I'm Dumbo.
What's his name?
Daffy.
What's this guy's name?
Silly?
Dopey.
What are you doing?
Doki?
Dumpy.
Where are you?
When are you beating Minecraft Hardcore...
Into modem mode?
Oh my gosh, dude.
His favorite struggle part of this collab...
Was you two...
You two struggling to read text with the scrolling screen...
Designed for 5 year olds.
What are you talking about?
It was going so fast.
There was so much information.
Okay.
Otsumita, thank you guys.
See you when I see you next.
Bye bye.
This was so much fun.
I hope you had fun too.
Bye bye.
Otsumita, itterasshoi.
Itterasshoi.
Bye bye.